[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález algunos
expertos dicen que estamos viviendo una
de las mayores crisis de transporte
marítimo y de suministros de la historia
moderna una conjunción perfecta de
diferentes factores que han provocado
escasez de muchos productos y también el
aumento de los precios sin precedentes
en minutos veremos cuáles son
precisamente esos factores la llamada
crisis de los suministros o la crisis de
los contenedores también ha golpeado con
fuerza a eeuu a europa también a china
pero américa latina' también se ha visto
afectada ya vamos a ver en qué forma y
la mala noticia es que no parece que
pueda solucionarse de manera inmediata
el gobierno de eeuu ha dicho que tal vez
puedan empezar a ver algunas soluciones
a partir del año entrante veamos el
siguiente reporte
hasta donde alcanza la vista la cola de
buques y sus contenedores multicolores
se extienden en los puertos
estadounidenses los de los ángeles y
long beach principalmente
en todos los barcos están en el océano
queremos trabajar pero mira ahora mismo
no podemos hacer nada cada vez a medida
que se acercan las fiestas de fin de año
la administración estadounidense pidió a
las empresas de transporte y logística
que trabajan día y noche para desatascar
los puertos de
forster se trata de un primer paso clave
para trasladar toda nuestra cadena de
transporte y suministro nacional a un
sistema 24/7 en sus más de 20 meses
después de que el brote inicial de
coronavirus obligará a china a cerrar
fábricas y dejará de funcionar la mayor
máquina exportadora del mundo el flujo
mundial de mercancías sigue siendo un
desastre las causas son múltiples y una
crisis alimenta a la otra inicialmente
las duras restricciones en china
europa paralizaron embarques desde el
resto del mundo los puertos se
congestionaron de buques que no pudieron
ni descargar ni cargar al mismo tiempo
la pandemia cerró fábricas y ralentizó
la producción global pero luego de este
colapso mundial del comercio surgió un
vigoroso aumento de la demanda de bienes
locales e importados una gran parte de
los cuales se transportan en buques
portacontenedores y las principales
potencias productoras como el sudeste
asiático luchan por seguir el ritmo ante
este panorama los costes de transporte
están destinados a explotar las empresas
que habían tratado de evitar llevar
estos costes a los clientes podrían
verse en la necesidad de hacerlo a
medida que la crisis de suministro se
prolonga
en este episodio del debate de france 24
analizaremos cuál es la situación su
posible solución y sobre todo en qué
consiste vamos a ponerlo en palabras y
en simples para poder entender qué es lo
que está sucediendo y cómo se traduce
eso para el bolsillo del consumidor hoy
en el debate crisis de suministros la
tormenta perfecta para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a magdalena vas a
litio ella es investigadora postdoctoral
del instituto de derechos humanos y
empresarias de la universidad de
monterrey también es doctora en
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad nacional de la plata en
argentina está también con nosotros
daniela dibella es periodista de
negocios y tecnología fue editora
adjunta de la revista fortune en español
y aquí en el estudio de france 24 está
con nosotros guillermo sinisterra
analista económico y también docente de
macroeconomía avanzada y también de
finanzas de la pontificia universidad
javeriana en la ciudad de bogotá ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en facebook
en instagram en twitter síganos como
france24
france24 mejor
s sant y luego les recuerdo que la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
pues quiero comenzar entonces con
guillermo aquí en el estudio de france
24 veíamos en el reportaje previo las
causas que llevaron a esta crisis de
suministros pero lo que uno pregunta
para iniciar este debate o lo que le
quiero preguntar guillermo es si faltó
una coordinación a nivel internacional
para esa reapertura económica después
del gran momento en que el mundo entero
estaba en un confinamiento y el mundo
prácticamente se paralizó pues santiago
la verdad es que es muy muy muy difícil
poder coordinar una operación logística
de ese nivel o sea estamos hablando que
el mundo entero se paralizó el mundo
entero estuvo quieto en todas las líneas
de suministro durante todo el tiempo y
tan pronto llegaron las vacunas y
comenzaron a aplicarse de manera masiva
en diferentes sectores la economía
comenzó todo el mundo comenzó a pedir
bienes y servicios y comenzó a pedirlos
ya o sea yo quiero todo y lo quiero ya
era es lo que está pasando pero las
fábricas no tenían materias primas las
líneas de producción estaban oxidadas y
digamos que faltó no solamente
coordinación sino que cogió por sorpresa
el aumento en la demanda tan
extraordinario que se dio entonces eso
fue lo que magdalena bach bilis yo le
pregunto lo mismo faltó una coordinación
a nivel internacional para poder
engranar los diferentes puntos que hacen
parte de estas cadenas de suministros
cuál es su opinión
creo que faltó coordinación como faltó
coordinación también a nivel de la
pandemia o sin demia entre los estados
pensemos por ejemplo en algunos
productos en particular
vacunas contra la cob y 19 que recién me
mi colega las mencionaba en este caso
tenemos un ejemplo muy claro es
latinoamérica desde argentina se
fabricaba el principio activo para la
vacuna de astrazéneca sin embargo el mba
los envases y el embotellado se
realizaba en méxico hubo problemas con
el suministro de los envases en méxico
tenían al principio huevo pero no la
forma ni los objetos para embotellar los
falta coordinación pero también hay
otros problemas que son subyacentes por
ejemplo los retrasos en la vacunación de
los empleados el aumento en el costo de
los fletes otros problemas vinculados
con el cambio climático
puntualmente las exigencias que cada vez
más se están dando desde la sociedad
civil y desde la sociedad en general 10
cadenas globales de suministro más
limpias y más ecológicas
y daniela para cerrar esta primera ronda
de preguntas cuál es su opinión sobre
esta sobre esta situación esta falta de
coordinación que es como lo yo lo he
puesto sobre la mesa pero pues ustedes
han añadido otros puntos específicos
sí pues además de la falta de
coordinación que resulta pues bastante
complicada considerando lo integrada que
está la cadena de suministro
prácticamente en todo el mundo y que
como ya lo mencionaron se evidenció esta
dependencia pues un poco peligrosa
cuando salió
cuando comenzó la pandemia
realmente en regiones como latinoamérica
algo un problema particularmente
complejo ahorita que se ha reabierto la
economía porque es una región que
también ha estado incrementando en su
consumo de comercio digital lo cual
también exige que la cadena de
suministro de una región que está
creciendo opere de la manera más óptima
entonces al mismo tiempo en el que se
reabre la economía los consumidores
empiezan a demandar más cosas llega en
un momento bastante complejo para todo
lo que está ocurriendo a nivel mundial
porque pues la demanda sobrepasa muy
rápidamente
la oferta entonces no hay tampoco una
manera de haberla solucionado de manera
tan fácil desde un principio la
coordinación es desde hace muchos años
entonces ex hacer el problema desde hace
muchos años daniela sigo con usted para
hacer la ronda a la inversa y le
pregunto entonces algo que leí de
algunos analistas sobre este tema y
dicen que esto simplemente es la punta
del iceberg quien es simplemente este
problema en los puertos de china y en
los puertos de eeuu y europa con muchos
barcos tratando de llegar para descargar
con tiempos muchos más largos de espera
en los slots en los puertos para luego
cargar y regresar
a que entonces nos estamos enfrentando
qué es lo que podemos ver más allá de la
punta del iceberg
claro pues es un problema que se
dimensiona desde varios lugares
principalmente por el hecho de que el
problema de los chips e los de los
semiconductores revela que solamente un
solo país
taiwán en este caso concentra el 60% de
la producción de microchips esto como ya
se mencionaba antes vienen es una
política del país de los años 70 en el
cual se determina que gran parte de la
fabricación de estos microchips se va a
ocurrir y va a ser una política
económica fuerte del país y simplemente
como ya se mencionaba se revela el hecho
de que la cadena de suministro está
completamente pues tocada no está está a
nivel internacional y es sólo un ejemplo
de lo que puede venir después si
magdalena de la ciudad de monterrey está
entonces esto dejándonos en evidencia
que la cadena de suministro a nivel
internacional está muy concentrada en
unos puntos muy específicos por ejemplo
8 de los 10 puertos más grandes o más
dinámicos del mundo están en china y
desde ahí es de donde se mueve la gran
cantidad de carga a nivel internacional
y pues prácticamente todos los países
están comerciando con china entonces
dependemos de ese punto de partida
también rutas establecidas que son
controladas y estamos viendo entonces
que la cadena es como una forma de
cremallera muy cerrada
y es cierto creo que el episodio de el
ever viven en el canal de suez nos dio
un excelentísimo ejemplo del problema
que tú recién planteaste que quiero
decir con esto
un buque atascado en uno de los
principales canales del mundo que recibe
el 13 por ciento aproximadamente del
comercio mundial vía marítima y hoy en
por el cual cruza en unos 40 buques al
día hizo que casi tambalear a la
globalización algo que no habíamos visto
hasta el momento ni siquiera la pandemia
no había mostrado de una manera tan
clara
y
aumento tan importante de algunos puntos
del mundo nos demuestra que las cadenas
de suministro al ser internacionales se
hacen cada vez más complejas el problema
tal vez no es la internacionalización
sino la complejidad que esto genera puse
el ejemplo de las vacunas podríamos
poner el ejemplo de una computadora cada
una de las piezas de la computadora
probablemente sea fabricada en
diferentes puntos transportada vía
marítima hasta un lugar donde se
ensamble luego de allí otra empresa
porque también vemos el fenómeno de la
tercerización realice la distribución
para un continente completo como puede
ser américa latina
y luego empresas y aquí introdujo otro
tema que no es meramente el transporte
marítimo y luego empresas por ejemplo de
transporte carretero son las encargadas
de realizar la distribución y este es el
otro gran problema que estamos
encontrando el transporte carretero
además de los problemas en el transporte
marítimo además de las restricciones no
arancelarias
usted menciona ya le doy la palabra
guillermo magdaleno se menciona la
globalización que es un hecho pues que
ya está más analizado a lo largo de las
últimas décadas pero creo que entonces
lo que nos enseña esto y también el
episodio del canal de suez es que
globalización es directamente
proporcional a inmediatez no puede haber
globalización sin necesidad de que
tengamos que tener todo tan inmediato
como decía guillermo que empezó la
reapertura económica y queríamos todo ya
los anaqueles lleno los supermercados
llenos los almacenes llenos y tal vez la
globalización no puede cumplir ese
factor de inmediatez como lo vio usted
magdalena
bien interesante la pregunta porque se
está viendo un fenómeno o se había
comenzado a analizar un fenómeno antes
de la pandemia vinculado al ruiz
sourcing esto es la globalización es el
momento clave del offshoring sin embargo
volver a producir volver a almacenar y
transportar desde el territorio
con la pandemia o sin demia esto tal vez
cambio por las propias necesidades de la
producción y los problemas puntuales que
se estaban dando en algunas regiones del
planeta más que más que otras pero me
parece bien interesante tener presente
que no necesariamente la retirada de la
hiper globalización como lo mencionan
dani rodrik tiene que ser sinónimo de
terminar con el offshoring yo creo que
vamos a seguir teniendo offshoring pero
con una tendencia paulatina veremos en
el futuro continúa así
comenzar a producir dentro de las
regiones el ejemplo de la unión europea
con el ibuprofeno
creo que es un ejemplo bien claro soy yo
se fabrica así si guillermo aquí en el
estudio france24 lo que hemos visto en
las noticias y lo que hemos reportado a
lo largo de estos días es que el
problema está básicamente estados unidos
con sus puertos que recientemente por
orden presidencial orden federal están
trabajando 24 horas al día los 7 días de
la semana para poder agilizar los
procesos también china está tratando de
reactivarse pero esto no solamente
afecta a china ya estados unidos a la
unión europea como se ve entonces
afectada américa latina' en este caso
bueno américa latina como está dentro de
los países emergentes tiene unas líneas
de producción que digamos dependen menos
de la cadena global de suministro
entonces esto pues obviamente las
grandes empresas también están están muy
alineadas con la cadena de suministro
internacional pero américa latina tiene
entre comillas la ventaja de que las
cosas que se producen son cosas que
dependen de básicamente el sector minero
del sector de materias primas y esas
producciones se hacen con todos los
insumos dentro de los países tenemos
algunas tecnologías importadas y todo
esto pero todo esto para decir que el
impacto sobre américa latina yo creo que
va a ser menor que el impacto para para
para europa eeuu o china hay una cosa
importante en nosotros vamos a tener un
impacto negativo de otra clase nosotros
vamos a tener un impacto negativo muy
grande si estos problemas en la cadena
de suministro de los países
desarrollados comienzan a impactar el
crecimiento económico y comienzan a
impactar digamos el ingreso y comienzan
a llegar menos divisas de américa
latina' ahí sí vamos a tener un que es
un escenario que ya puede estar pasando
entonces ahí sí vamos a tener un
golpe fuerte al poder adquisitivo de
muchas personas que dependen de lo que
llamamos las remesas que para allá iba
mi pregunta entonces directamente que no
golpe muy fuerte la región pero entonces
si esto empieza a afectar
el crecimiento económico de eeuu o esa
reactivación de eeuu que es tal vez uno
de los principales jugadores económicos
en la región y también de china que es
el principal socio ya en américa latina
ahí sí nos va a empezar entonces a
frenar a nosotros la reactivación
económica que le ha costado tanto a los
países por supuesto o sea en este
momento nosotros estamos teniendo
tres veces más el ingreso por ejemplo
colombia está teniendo tres veces más el
ingreso de remesas
que lo que exporta en café que todo el
mundo está muy orgulloso del café
entonces las remesas son supremamente
importantes si eeuu se comienza a
desacelerar como está pasando por la
inflación por las cadenas de suministro
porque en muchos sectores no sean no se
han comenzado a digamos no sean
no sean todavía adaptado a la nueva
realidad porque los trabajadores están
renunciando o sea es una tormenta
perfecta como ustedes lo dijeron al
principio del programa yo sí creo que
vamos a tener un costo alto en cuanto a
menos capital entrando al país eso va a
tener efectos sobre nuestra tasa de
cambio porque va a haber menos dólares
disponibles entonces la clase cambio
probablemente se va a evaluar y pues
digamos vamos a ver las consecuencias
daniela en la ciudad de mexico en la
capital mexicana le pregunto en ese
orden de ideas de acuerdo a lo que
explica guillermo se estarían conjugando
muchos factores a una rápida velocidad
generando un efecto de bola de nieve
para volver a tener de tal vez un
colapso financiero o un colapso
económico a nivel internacional en el
futuro como lo ve usted
pues es es complicado predecirlo como un
colapso económico pero definitivamente
va a afectar a la región como ya dijo
guillermo en cuanto a las remesas y la
disponibilidad de divisas pero también
en el tema inflacionario el fondo
monetario internacional recientemente
anunció que la región de latinoamérica
será la que más inflación la que mayor
inflación tenga para finales de 2020 1
arriba del 9 por ciento y gméxico será
una de las economías que influye y que
empuje este crecimiento casi el doble
dígito
y también afecta a regiones como brasil
y el propio país en mi libro mi país en
donde estoy puesto que son dos de los
productores principales de vehículos en
la región que también han sido pues
afectados por la falta de microchips y
la distribución de este tipo de
elementos algo que también es importante
destacar es que viene la temporada
decembrina la temporada en una de las
más altas en términos de ventas e
insisto con el crecimiento del ecommerce
en la región lo que es algo importante
que está empujando a que muchas empresas
que durante la pandemia tuvieron varias
pérdidas y se emigraron a la parte
digital estuvieron creciendo y ahorita
por el problema de la cadena de
suministro pueden pues ver también verse
también afectadas entonces digamos que a
corto plazo tendremos que ver en enero
cómo sobreviven estas economías después
de la de una de las temporadas más
importantes y definitivamente pues los
analistas estiman que hasta 2022 se
podrá pues bajar un poco el tema
inflacionario y se podrá establecer un
poco la normalidad del tema de la la la
cadena de suministro global
magdalena en la región de américa latina
teniendo ya claro este panorama y como
esto nos va a golpear en un efecto
digamos un poco más tardío que a eeuu y
china ya la unión europea quienes van a
ser los más afectados los grandes
empresarios que existen en nuestros
países que se cuentan con los dedos de
las manos en algunos de ellos o el
empresario el mediano empresario también
que se cuentan con las manos de los
dedos después de la pandemia en algunos
de los países o el usuario el ciudadano
común el ciudadano a pie
creo que el principal afectado va a ser
el consumidor voy a poner un ejemplo que
consideró que es muy ilustrativo un
contenedor de 40 pies previo a la
pandemia y tenía un valor desde china a
montevideo uruguay dos mil dólares hoy
la cotización para el mismo contenedor
mismo trayecto son 14 mil dólares ese
monto se traslada al precio de los
productos por tanto el más afectado va a
ser el ciudadano la persona quien
consuma bienes todos los días
duda que en las empresas también van a
ser afectadas pero suelen ser en estos
casos las menos afectadas en la pregunta
es cuáles son las medidas que van a
tomar los estados para hacer frente a
esta situación para poder cuando llegar
a que los ciudadanos sean resilientes
frente a una situación que nos afecta
directamente porque afecta su poder
adquisitivo
magdaleno este toca justamente la
pregunta que va a poner sobre la mesa
para hacérsela a los tres para conocer
sus opiniones sobre este tema y es que
se puede hacer desde nuestras regiones
desde américa latina que estamos todavía
tratando de hacerle frente a la pandemia
kobe 19 algunos países que tienen menos
del 50% de la población con el esquema
completo de vacunación y vemos como
otros países están ya contemplando la
posibilidad de volver a cerrar sus
economías de cara al invierno por lo
menos algunos países europeos
guillermo aquí en el estudio france24
que se puede hacer en el marco de
nuestras economías que son tan
dependientes de las divisas y de iu de
diferentes temas externos yo creo que la
gran mayoría de países de américa latina
han reaccionado en términos
macroeconómicos de una manera adecuada
básicamente han tratado de que el
consumo no caiga cierto entonces para
eso tuvieron que dar unos grandes
esquemas de subsidios los cuales se han
mantenido durante este año probablemente
se van a mantener durante durante el
siguiente año algunos de ellos
están digamos teniendo en cuenta el tema
inflacionario y están comenzando a subir
tasas de interés que no están no es tan
bueno para la economía digámoslo así
pero es un es un es un enfriamiento de
la inflación galopante que se está dando
en nuestros países y en el mundo entero
entonces si nosotros queremos saber qué
hacer pues esa es la pregunta del millón
de dólares que yo creo que yo creo que
es una oportunidad para digamos re
adaptar nuestras nuestras líneas de
suministro para impulsar los productos
propios o sea no no estoy hablando de un
enfoque digamos de proteccionismo pero
sí un enfoque de impulsarlos pero los
productos nacionales no vino por al
claro no porque no porque digamos no por
nacionalismo o por ideología sino en
primer lugar es porque lo que tenemos a
la mano no y en segundo lugar es lo que
más rápidamente podemos comenzar a
utilizar y yo creo que es muy buen
momento para hacerlo porque esta crisis
muy probablemente va a ir a esta tercer
team tercer trimestre de 2022
están viendo los
analistas internacionales daniela su
opinión que hacer al respecto
coincido con guillermo en esta cuestión
de incentivar el consumo y el
pues si el transporte de los productos
que tenemos a nuestro alcance en las
economías regionales sin embargo
definitivamente hay productos en los
cuales todavía se va a depender de esta
cadena de suministro global
especialmente los tecnológicos todos los
eléctricos sin duda alguna no hay que
hay que quitarle o el reglón en que va a
ser un proceso largo pero
definitivamente esta cuestión de que los
gobiernos sigan apoyando a los pequeños
y medianos empresarios que son sin duda
uno de los más afectados aunque esta
pandemia afecta a todos pero estos
apoyos con subsidios y incentivando el
consumo también podrían servir sin
descuidar esta parte inflacionaria
porque sin duda aún cuando incluso el
presidente de eeuu ha mencionado que
esta escalada en precios a nivel
internacional a partir de sus de sus
propias empresas y productos es
transitoria sin duda no no se puede
puede dar subsidios por tanto tiempo
entonces sin duda volcar a ver las
economías locales tratar de detonar las
y por los consumidores si tendrán que
hacer un esfuerzo un poco más más
intenso para poder consumir de manera
local y reevaluar quizás su consumo de
electrónicos en algunos casos y además
que vemos que en algunos países de
américa latina los subsidios que
pudieron dar los gobiernos fueron para
las grandes empresas y para los bancos
en algunos casos no llegaron
precisamente a los medianos empresarios
oa los ciudadanos
eeuu porque tiene un músculo económico
ha logrado dos o tres subsidios
generosos a su sector económico y
productivo pero pero no estamos hablando
del mismo músculo en magdalena para
cerrar está esta pregunta que se puede
hacer
bueno coincido con mis colegas en cuanto
a el consumo local 13 es sustancial
hacer este foco en ese ítem y también al
apoyo al mediano y pequeño
empresario que es el que recibe los
golpes más fuertes de esta situación
pero también tomar la crisis como una
oportunidad de poner el ejemplo de la
reciente ley de cadenas de suministro
limpias y verdes ecológicas de alemania
que busca la debida diligencia de las
empresas en estas dos áreas que son
sustanciales derechos humanos y
protección del medio ambiente que en
toda la cadena internacional izada como
mencionábamos se combata el trabajo
infantil el trabajo esclavo o aquellas
prácticas que destruyen el medio
ambiente los momentos de crisis suelen
ser buenos momentos para repensar lo que
veníamos haciendo hasta ahora y comenzar
a diseñar el futuro tal vez este es el
momento de diseñar un futuro más ético y
más
buena reflexión a magdalena en la ciudad
de monterrey a en el norte de méxico la
crisis siempre será una oportunidad para
poder mejorar algunas de las cosas que
tenemos en marcha en este momento quiero
hablar ya para entrar en la recta final
del programa sobre esas declaraciones
que dio el secretario de transporte de
eeuu betis quien reconoció que este
proyecto es perdón este problema de la
cadena de suministro va a durar hasta el
año entrante y también se mostró dudoso
al respecto por aprovecho para hablar de
la ley de infraestructuras
entonces les quería preguntar si esto no
se toma esta crisis también para un poco
politizar guillermo un poco para
utilizar ese ambicioso plan de
infraestructuras que tienen hay en eeuu
porque de aprobarse y empezar a ponerlo
en marcha pues eso no va a solucionar la
crisis de suministro de la noche a la
mañana la crisis es ya y el plan pues se
demora en desarrollarse
entonces se confunden dos cosas la
política pero así funciona mucho la
economía americana
siempre se utiliza digamos una situación
crítica para chantajear al oponente en
una cosa que se estratégica para mí y
así funciona siempre pasó con el techo
de la deuda grita hace hace tres semanas
que los republicanos dijeron no vamos a
subir el techo de la deuda entonces y
bueno y entonces que quieren a no no no
queremos que no vayan estos proyectos no
tienen nada que ver con la estabilidad
macroeconómica de eeuu nidades entonces
eeuu juega mucho así yo creo que la el
plan de infraestructura de bailén que ha
estado ahí durante mucho tiempo y no se
ha podido justamente porque el congreso
no aprueba pero ahora es necesario ahora
ya no es que quieran o no quieran es una
muy buena jugada en esta época casi
todos los países uno de los renglones
que más están digamos utilizando para
generar el crecimiento económico es la
infraestructura porque pues tiene una
cantidad de materiales además de una
cantidad de materiales demanda mano de
obra demanda entonces yo creo que es
bueno que apele al plan de
infraestructura además de que es
estratégico para los demócratas porque
porque vienen elecciones importantes
ahorita entonces pero pero digamos que
yo creo que es una muy buena jugada del
secretario yo no creo que lo esté
politizando yo creo que en realidad el
país lo necesita magdalena' puntualmente
usted tocaba el tema y nos daba las
presas de lo que vale un flete desde
china hasta el puerto de montevideo me
llama la atención que por ejemplo
uruguay está negociando un tlc con china
en este momento en que no se puede
garantizar una cadena de suministros de
manera satisfactoria también se politiza
se puede avanzar en este tipo de
proyectos tan grandes en medio de esta
coyuntura
uruguay no está negociando un tratado de
libre comercio piensa hacerlo o están
planteadas las leyes está planteada la
situación como para que comience la
negociación pero aún no ha comenzado hay
algunos y no quisiera usar el término
escollo pero bueno hay algunos temas
jurídicos todavía dentro del mercosur a
seguir discutiendo
el tema del aumento del precio de los de
los fletes y cómo afecta como decíamos a
américa latina creo que siempre hay que
tener
presente que no es únicamente la
pandemia o la sinde mya hay muchos otros
factores que pueden estar influyendo las
navieras durante el 2020 tuvieron una
ganancia muy superior a años anteriores
por tanto el gran debate que estamos
teniendo en este momento es si el
aumento en el precio de los fletes es
únicamente por
problemas de vacunación de los
funcionarios en cuartos o en puntos de
frontera y menos funcionarios a esto se
le suma el aumento de la demanda o en
realidad también hay un
deseo de mayor lucro por parte de las
empresas empresas es un tema
traerá al debate que deberíamos seguir
analizando
si lastimosamente ya estamos llegando a
la recta final magdalena me quedan dos
minutos para hacer las conclusiones
comienzo por daniela en la ciudad de
mexico las conclusiones ya para la recta
final que va a suceder que piensa usted
que pueda suceder no tenemos bola de
cristal siempre lo digo yo en el cierre
del programa pero que cree usted que
pueda suceder con este tema
pues primero tendremos que ver cómo
cierra el año ya mencionaba que viene
una temporada importante en la cual será
una oportunidad también para incentivar
el consumo local
y sin duda como mencionaron mis colegas
era una buena oportunidad para que
regiones como la nuestra latinoamérica
que tampoco está tan pegada o depende
tanto como eeuu no de una cadena de
suministro con el sudeste asiático
podamos empezar a hacer este tipo de
decisiones que incentiven el consumo
local y también quizás como consumidores
sea importante como ya se mencionaba no
estar visto de qué manera estamos
consumiendo productos con una cadena de
suministro más ética y más verde si
guillermo por acá me lo estudio france24
su conclusión 30 segundos y yo creo que
vamos a tener una inflación
galopante hasta más o menos mediados o
el tercer trimestre del próximo año creo
que la situación en eeuu le va a pegar
el crecimiento
y creo que va eso eso nos va a afectar
indirectamente eso quiere decir que
haber una devaluación del dólar que no
estamos esperando porque tenemos muchas
divisas en este momento para colombia y
pero creo que todo va a ser temporal más
o menos seis meses magdalenas
rápidamente me quedan 30 segundos por
favor espero que la crisis sea una
oportunidad como decíamos para cadenas
globales de suministro más verdes y más
limpias pero también para mayor
autonomía de américa latina y no tanta
dependencia de estado como pueden ser
eeuu a china
daniela magdalena y a guillermo les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
en el programa habernos explicado en
palabras un poco más simples esta crisis
de suministros a nivel internacional y
habernos ayudado a armar este
rompecabezas ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
la programación de france 24
[Música]